[Applause]
yes Andrew Ross Sorkin do you agree with
Larry Kudlow that Medicare and Social
Security should be handed to Wall Street
through privatization is that what he's
for I'm sure I'm sure he is for it yeah
I think I'm for that no I'm gonna take
the other side of that is that what you
want me to go well I know what do you
weigh I think I chose this I think
that's a real problem
I think the privatization of so many
things actually especially when it comes
to people's pension retirement part of
our problem has been that so I would I'm
gonna take the other side but as an
economist who plays I'm just gonna give
you the other argument okay I've seen
the chart of where money if you put your
money in the stock market forces if you
just put it in the bank or whatever it
is it'll do better in the mark like the
market one goes like this now you can't
watch it every year cuz the market goes
up and down but over the time if you put
it in when you were twenty went by they
tell you retired at 65 look if the money
goes like this and if we hadn't forced
if we had a forced savings program I'm
just saying by the way if we had a real
for savings program where you couldn't
take it out and you couldn't and
somebody else and was effectively gonna
be managed elsewhere and there was a
guarantees on it I could have to go for
that it's not the craziest crazy to you
easier uncle here George Bush yeah he's
my he's my cousin and to think about
that there's a lot of us they're cousins
right dad's my uncle okay sure yes you
guys hang out there's a lot of us no not
much so Billy how was the rest of the
Bush family holding up under Trump this
card said I'm gonna take the high road I
think I don't know if he's right I'm not
sure either one cast that vote for him
I'd in fact I'm pretty sure they didn't
speaking of me to stuff Boyer or the old
man start sure skated on the have you
ever talked to him about that I told him
never again you hear me don't do that no
but yeah because there's a conservative
he did I mean it sounds like the same
thing you know that Al Franken was
accused of and that just kind of like
went into the ether okay
except Eva for he's a former President
of the United States
it's right you know people didn't know
that about and there's a whole bunch of
women that said it's pretty it's pretty
messed up pretty unacceptable and there
was a joke that went with it it's
disgusting and inexcusable right you are
well he's Pete what a lot of fun you are
well I mean okay
there's no upside to it yeah yeah I'm
with you I'm not sure what Al Franken
did I'll just say that I'm talking about
I'm talking about Pappy either one I
mean who who's grabbing or what in a
photo op it's weird
it is weird especially and have you
everybody wants a photo with Bill Maher
have you ever even considered you I'll
even touch your two cultures like yes
exactly hands up
why does the NRA get a tax exemption and
how do we take it away they do run they
would like to say that they don't want a
political action committee but they do
have that wing and otherwise they say
they're grassroots nonprofit
organization but they've used a legal
corporate tax loopholes to build out an
entire political lobbying wing that
doesn't get taxed so that that is that's
a corporate tax loophole but that's also
because the NRA knows how to work the
system boy do they by the way and then
how to use a crisis but but I'll never
let a crisis go to waste all the money
on the NRA now we're arming teachers you
know yet
they somehow turn that or what sure yeah
it's moving ahead in many states somehow
they turn that around to a way they
could sell more guns it's moving ahead
in the states where they still beat kids
with paddles I mean it's not you know I
don't think it's taking hold I don't
it's not there's no agreement with lunch
eggs educators and experts about arming
teachers teachers don't want that well
they go is just gonna say on money on
the NRA you know you could go after them
on the taxes or whatever it is but the
real thing the real opportunity given I
cover cover the world of finance is the
companies it's all the companies that do
business with the NRA and people who do
business with guns it's the credit card
companies that allow the transactions on
the cards it's Apple TV and Amazon and
everybody who allows this stuff over
their airwaves
that's your Washington unfortunately is
not gonna do anything I don't think any
soon I could be wrong I hope I'm wrong
but I think in the meantime there's a
huge swath of stuff that can actually
happen but it depends on everybody
actually so the action related to your
pocketbook right consumers have to wait
about two years before we can use our
powers citizens to kick somebody out of
office I can make a decision tomorrow if
I want to go to a different store if I
don't like like Walmart Walmart business
they got the business of a lot of people
right but Dick's Sporting Goods did yeah
I got uh I got paddled a couple of times
hey now destroy me no but only when you
do something really bad you know and or
anything no question what kind of
paddling is talking about maybe we
should move on
I'm just saying have you worked in the
White House would you resign on
principle or stay to help minimize the
damage Trump causes oh so I I don't
think there's any heroism and serving in
this White House anymore I think
initially people really did think that
John Kelly like I'm gonna serve my
country and do this but it's you're not
serving the public at this point right
you're serving Trump and his personal
Trump interests and that's that's just
not and you don't know what they are
right but the very clear what they are
actually they're advancing his family
and and and where else is willing to
line as pocketbooks whether it be
Russian oligarchs or any other dictators
that he may or may not want to emulate
but there is and I guess I I did work in
the White House and there's absolutely
no question that I would ever work in a
Trump White House and the sad thing is
everybody who's walked out has walked
out tarnished like it's it's yeah and
it's a dead-end job
Icarus fly close to the Sun yes no but
anyone has a better reputation than Sean
Spicer would you want John Daly Monica
Lewinsky is doing better bro why isn't
Sean Spicer anybody as you can attest
anyone who gets in contact with he's a
human wood chipper people just right you
don't know is you know to a job to
Donald Trump you shouldn't be running a
mess
problem I do want to throw in about
public like public servants who are I
was a political appointee there are
public servants in the Foreign Service
the military civil servants who keep the
day-to-day function of government
running the fact that they are feeling
demoralized
is a massive problem because they're the
ones who make sure we get things like
our Social Security checks all we can
say is the real problem though is if
look you can call all the people who
showed up in the beginning and
opportunists which they are today
they're the new people are believers and
fortunately or unfortunately fortunately
for Trump and unfortunately the best
part - and villain but but that but the
opportunist to the degree you thought
that they were saving the country from
Trump those people don't exist in yeah
and so I think there has to be there has
to be some thought about whether you do
want some diversity of thought in the
room even if it ain't people I don't
know what the right answer is he has to
want the diversity of thought he doesn't
exactly right so like what do you get
out of serving like that doesn't fix
anything
that's what they're but that's what
they're claiming these days all over TV
is that he would be that that's why
there's this turnover because he he has
this but he likes to see people go at it
I like to see people go at it this is
how we know him the boardroom I mean
this is how he's the host of The
Apprentice firing he instigates he's
about selling lemonade on a corner
what's the Avenue but like it wasn't all
there for us to judge think he'd be able
to take business savvy and apply that to
politics and all these other things and
and policy maybe so many people yes and
it's shady business deals that's the
wrong it works in real estate it doesn't
work and don't windows your own policy
how many of those bojay convinces my
question how many of those voters that
he did convince you know have have
changed their mind or more importantly
did has anybody said since Trump was
elected you know I was really against
him the whole time but at these 14
months he's really impressed me I think
I'm gonna reconsider my vote to November
that's like one guy who's a pig farmer
there are I think all right real thank
you everybody okay thank you
you